the war of the ninepenny kings that
calls it but I never saw a king who
earned a penny after the war ended I
heard it all started when an exiled
royal bastard raised an army of sell
swords and the rightful king sent his
own army to stop an invasion sounds
simple the way the maesters tell it but
an army isn't like a dog that comes when
you whistle the king calls on great
lords who call on lesser laws who send
out their captains to round up all the
peasant men on the land the Lord claims
to own if the Lord is wise and generous
his new soldiers had given steel swords
and wooden shields to fight his battles
most of our army fought with sharp
sticks singers still singer the valiant
heroes made in the war Sabrina and Tully
the blackfish Sir Tywin Lannister and
Prince Aerys Targaryen sir Barristan
Selmy the bold who slew the bastard
pretender and ended the war at a stroke
but the king whose crown we were
defending never came he mattered too
much I suppose his hand commanded the
Crown's armies and died valiantly in his
son's arms oh so the singers say I never
saw that either I did see the soldiers
when they came to our village it
declared I was too young to fight but my
brothers and Friends were all going and
I wouldn't be left behind
my oldest brother said I could be his
squire though he wasn't a knight just a
pop boy armed with a stolen kitchen
knife he'd never need it I saw him
collapse on a March and favor along with
many from our village I saw our shoes
fall apart on the road our clothes rot
off our bodies and half of us [ __ ]
our beds from the sickness in fear and
then we got to the wall in the step
stones I saw a mace cave in my last
brother's head I saw the Lord who led us
there cut down on some other lords shout
that we were is now one day I looked
around I realized all my friends and kin
were gone that was fighting beside
strangers under a banner I'd never seen
didn't know where I was or how to get
when a Lord rode up shouting at us to
form ranks with our size and Mo's I
couldn't remember which side I was on
then the Knights came down on us
faceless men all they'd steal the
thunder of their charge filled the world
I close my eyes
years later after the war had faded into
songs I opened them again and saw what I
had done and what I had become
in the war and since I went looking for
a way back home I know I'll never reach
it but that doesn't mean I don't need a
guide